les états unis devient un exportateur
net de pétrole ça ne veut pas dire
qu'ils ne portent pas de pétrole non
plus mais mais en termes de net
ils sont exportateurs peut-on dire que
l'enjeu du pétrole et moins central dans
le conflit actuel iran irak états unis
par rapport à la guerre du koweït en
1990 ben oui je pense que oui il ya
plusieurs raisons pour cela une raison
importante c'est que les économies
développées sont beaucoup moins
intensive d'énergie donc c'est sûr que
le prix du pétrole a augmenté beaucoup
il ya aussi tout ce qui est relié à des
réductions de d'émissions de gaz à effet
de serre donc c'est ça a mené à des
enfants de réduire essentielle ment
l'intensité d'énergétique donc aux états
unis c'est comme c'est le cas le plus
important c'est moins sensibles à des
hausses de prix du pétrole a pour cette
raison là mais aussi par le fait que
l'économie américaine est moins sensible
parce que effectivement comme le canada
quand une hausse de prix du pétrole
certaines secteurs comme le secteur
après tu relis certaines régions comme
l'alberta où le texas qui en bénéficient
et donc c'est ea aide à commander à
balancer avec les effets négatifs d'une
hausse de prix super tri et d'ailleurs
c'est quoi l'implication dans l'équation
géopolitique internationale actuelle ce
qui se passe présentement quelles
implications pour le canada mais en fait
pour le canada c'est sûr que une hausse
de prix du pétrole on est encore un
producteur important de pétrole
c'est sûr qu'il ya des effets négatifs
bien sûr quand on regarde des effets
d'une hausse de prix du pétrole sur les
consommateurs canadiens comme américains
et autres amiens en est c'est un soutien
positif parce qu'on est très dépendant
et on exporte beaucoup de notre source
est nette de nos ressources et des
énergétique
faut-il s'attendre à une hausse des
cours du pétrole dans les prochains mois
écoutez on a vu une situation en fait la
situation présente je pense qu'elle va
créer beaucoup plus de volatilité comme
on l'a vu dans les derniers jours je
pense que le prix du pétrole qui convoie
fait à la fin de la journée aujourd'hui
juste au dessus des 60 dollars
c'est un peu
c'est un peu une réflexion de la demande
et et production mondiale donc c'est il
ya beaucoup de production est faite
séjour pour pau en terme de la demande
mondiale c'est un marché qui t'ont pense
que le pétrole devrait être à ce niveau
là c'est 60 $ us
mais maintenant s'ils attirent une
escale à sion quelconque c'est sûr qu'on
pourrait voir j'ai pris beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus volatile et roanne tout
neuf merci beaucoup
moi ça me fait plaisir